Very much believe that they should.
It's an important component and we
mustn't let that slip.
It does a certain amount of feeling does
a financial crisis,
can we really afford?
We have to because we have a very
connected world and what what's
happening in other parts of the world
will ultimately affect us unless you
have social stability.
So it is in the outcome document of this
summer that there must be a recommitment
to the 0.7% of GDP,
which is actually not a great amount
given the potential of being able to
have a safer and more balanced world.
We also know now that the way in which
we're living our lives based on carbon
in the rich parts of the world is
undermining development of the poorest
parts.
And there's a commitment that was made
in Copenhagen for an additional $30
billion a year over the next three years
to help the poorest and most vulnerable
countries.
I want to see that money as yet I don't
see any new money being committed by
countries.
And even though there's a financial
crisis,
we can actually find the ability.
And then we need governments of the poor
countries to have a real sense of their
responsibility to govern on behalf of
their people.
They very much understand the stress and
the worry and the day to day concerns of
people who have,
um,
terrible mortgage problems who are
behind on their payments,
who,
uh,
know that they have problems of school
fees or university fee fees for the
young people,
et Cetera.
And it's the same in the modern Ireland.
We're going through a very tough time
and many countries in Europe and
elsewhere.
Uh,
but we have to see the connections in
our world.
I mean,
look at a country that has become what
we call now a failed stays pretty well.
Somalia,
you have pirates out on the open seas
from Somalia.
You have a danger of terrorist being
able to group where there is no law and
order and find ways of attacking,
um,
uh,
elsewhere in the world.
We are much more interconnected than we
have ever been.
It's in our total interests to help to
create middle classes in the developing
countries.
Then they will buy American goods.
They will want to trade to the profit of
everyone.
Um,
so I think it's,
it's hard when you're really wondering
how you're going to meet the commitments
for next month and a real worries about,
about food as,
as,
as a woman has said.
But in fact,
uh,
I think any kind of sense of political
leadership now has to move in the
direction of understanding the
interconnections between our world.
And we will not have peace and security
if we do not have fairer balances
because we're not staying at the same
population level.
We're going to go up from just under 7
billion people today to over 9 billion
by 2050.
That's the largest increase in
population will ever seen.
And many of them are in very poor
countries.
So for stability for our own generation,
but particularly for our children and
grandchildren,
we have to have the sense of an
interconnected world.
I still firmly believe we need to keep
the commitments to development aid,
but I also agree with an increasing
number of African leaders and others who
say,
we want to bring ourselves out of
poverty,
we want fairer trade rules,
we want some subsidies removed.
That disadvantages and when we're trying
to compete on cotton or sugar,
etc. And,
um,
I think that we need to have more
emphasis on access to energy for the
poorest.
One of the things that has helped poor
countries greatly is the mobile phone.
That was the private sector,
uh,
creating a markers in the poor countries
and the mobile phone.
You know,
it attracts markets.
It transfers money,
it does help.
Surveyance it's how you can do education
on.
It's wonderful,
but there are 1.6 billion people who
have no access to electricity in our
21st century.
That's not acceptable.
If you give energy to the poorest,
they will be able to be more productive.
And there is that sense that age
shouldn't be sort of,
um,
kind of,
uh,
we look after your needs and not make
the poor productive.
Many of us think that we have to have
much more emphasis on decent work as
part of the whole approach,
including by the private sector.
The companies that are operating like
Coca Cola or other companies in
developing countries must more and more
look at their whole value chain.
How do we create more jobs?
It's jobs that take people out of
poverty.